an electronics warehouse ships
televisions and dvd players and certain
combinations to retailers throughout the
country
they tell us that the weight of three
televisions and five dvd players is 62.5
pounds and the weight of three
televisions and two dvd players so
they're giving us different combinations
is 52 pounds create a system of
equations that represents the situation
then solve it to find out how much each
television and dvd player weighs well
the two pieces of information they gave
us and each of these
statements can be converted into an
equation the first one is is that the
weight of three televisions weight of
three televisions and five dvd players
is 62.5 pounds
then they told us
that the weight of three televisions and
two dvd players is 52 pounds so we can
translate these directly into equations
if we let t to be the weight of a
television and d to be the weight of a
dvd player this first statement up here
says that three
times the weight of a television or
three televisions plus five times the
weight of a dvd player is going to be
equal to
62.5 pounds that's exactly what this
first statement is telling us the second
statement the weight of three television
and 2vd and two dvd players so if i have
three
televisions and two dvd players so the
weight of three televisions plus the
weight of two dvd players they're
telling us that that is
52 pounds and so now we've set up the
system of equation we've done the first
part to create a system that represents
the situation now we need to solve it
now one thing that's especially tempting
when you have two systems and both of
them have something whereas you know you
have a 3t here and you have a 3t here
what we can do is we can
multiply one of the systems by some
factor so that if we were to add this
equation to that equation we would get
one of the terms to cancel out and
that's what we're going to do right here
and you can do this you can do this
business of adding equations to each
other because remember when we learned
this at the beginning of algebra
anything you do to one side of equation
if i add 5 to one side of an equation i
have to add 5 to another side of the
equation so if i add this business to
this side of the equation if i add this
blue stuff to this to the left side of
the equation
i can add this 52 to the right hand side
because this is saying that 52 is the
same thing as this thing over here this
thing is also 52. so if we're adding
this to the left hand side we're
actually adding 52 to it we're just
writing it a different way now before we
do that what i want to do is multiply
the second blue equation by a negative
one
and i want to multiply it by negative
one
so negative three t plus i could write
negative two d is equal to negative 52.
so i haven't changed the information
this equation i just multiplied
everything by negative 1. the reason why
i did that is because now if i add these
two equations these three t terms are
going to cancel out so let's do that
let's add these two equations and
remember all we're doing is we're adding
the same thing to both sides of this top
equation we're adding essentially
negative 52 now now that we've
multiplied everything by a negative 1.
this negative 3t plus negative 2d is the
same thing as negative 52. so let's add
this left-hand side over here the 3t and
the negative 3t will cancel out that was
the whole point 5d plus negative a 2d is
3d
so you have a 3d is equal to 62.5 plus
negative 52 or 62.5 minus 52 is 10.5
is 10.5 and now we can divide both sides
of this equation by 3
divide both sides by 3 and you get d is
equal to 10.5 divided by 3. so let's
figure out what that is
three goes into
10.5 it goes into ten
three times three times three is nine
subtract
get one bring down the five
of course you have your decimal point
right here 3 goes into 15 five times 5
times 3 is 15. you got to subtract and
you get a zero so it goes exactly 3.5
times so the weight of a dvd player
that's what d represents is 3.8
pounds now we can substitute back into
one of these equations up here to figure
out the weight of a television we can
just use that top equation
so you get 3t
3t
plus 5 times the weight of a dvd player
which we just figured out is 3.5
remember we're just looking for values
that satisfy both of these equations so
5 times 3.5 need to be equal to 62.5
needs to equal 62.5 so you get 3t
plus what is this going to be this is
going to be 15
plus 2.5 right 5 times 0.5 is 2.5 5
times 3 is 15 so it's 17.5
is equal to 62.5
now we can subtract 17.5 from both sides
of this equation
subtract
17.5 subtracting 17.5
and what do we get the left-hand side is
just going to be 3t
this cancels out that was the whole
point of it
3t is going to be equal to let's see the
0.5 minus 0.5 that cancels out so this
is the same thing as 62 minus 17
minus 7 is would be 55 and so we're
going to subtract another 10 so it's
going to be 45
so this is going to be equal to 45. now
you can divide both sides of this
equation by
3. and we get t is equal to 15. so we've
solved our system the weight of a dvd
player is 3.5 pounds and the weight of a
television is 15 pounds and we're done